buenas tardes la estrategia del reino
unido para volver a un nuevo tipo de
normalidad y evitar un nuevo
confinamiento unas nuevas restricciones
a las libertades se basan en dos
premisas una es la campaña de vacunación
es reunido acusados al momento 37
millones de personas entre ellas 5
millones y medio que han recibido las
dosis completas de estos inyecciones y
también el reino unido es el país que
avanza más eficientemente en este
campaña de vacunación la otra premisa es
el testeo masivo de la población para
encontrar esos casos que no son fáciles
de identificar por ello a partir de este
viernes 9 de abril todos los adultos con
síntomas los sin síntomas poblanas del
26 de coronavirus completamente es
gratis no fue recibir online o pueden
hacerse en puntos específicos o en
farmacias para justamente encontrar esos
casos ha dicho el primer ministro
sobre el pasaporte de vacunas el
prefiere llamarlo el certificado de
vacunación que tienen sus reparos
reparos éticos y también se saben por
qué por ejemplo las mujeres embarazadas
no pueden recibir las vacunas así que es
un asunto todavía así tanto de la menta
no se ha tomado una decisión definitiva
pero lo cierto es que sería necesario no
solamente a nivel local como para poder
regresar a los eventos masivos como
festivales de música el fútbol pero
también en caso de la biblio pedrales
decida que este será un requisito para
viajar el verano entonces hay un hilo
con su puesto central 5 le ronda lo que
es gran parte de los británicos suele
tomar sus vacaciones de verano en los
países del mediterráneo
gracias a luisa por este reporte
dándonos detalles de estos anuncios
recientes que ha hecho el gobierno
británico en torno a las restricciones
impuestas a los ciudadanos un
levantamiento leve de algunas de las
medidas pero sigue siendo una
incertidumbre en torno a los viajes al
extranjero